members of ukraine security services run
for cover as the sound of a shell cuts
through the air and explodes close by
in the basement a group of elderly
residents is hiding
during a brief lull they emerge from the
shelter dazed and terrified
the police tell them to get into the
vehicle quickly
another shell explodes
their car passes a body on the street
just a few kilometers south the wreckage
of what were people's homes still burns
this is lizzy chansk one of the two
remaining cities that russia doesn't
control in the luganz region
the ukrainian army says russian forces
have destroyed the last of three bridges
that used to connect the city with
neighboring sierra donetsk over the
river to the north
potentially making it very difficult for
soldiers volunteer units and what the
ukrainian military says are many
civilians refusing to leave or trapped
inside
we are civilians why are they shelling
us as if junior we don't have anyone
here no soldiers why are they bombing
says her friend
they stand by a grave where one of their
two neighbours was hastily buried in
recent days
and they all ask this question why don't
you leave but where are we supposed to
go this is our land we grow up here we
live here our mothers and fathers are
buried here in the cemetery
these residents line up to get water
from a fire truck ukrainian authorities
say there's been no water or electricity
for days
unexploded rockets are stuck in the
earth and rubble people here say russian
shelling is increasing all the time
they started shooting very hard
many people began to leave
or at least the ones who had somewhere
to go
military analysts say most of ukraine's
soviet-built weaponry has been destroyed
ukrainian army says it needs more
long-range artillery and tanks if it is
to stop the russian advance ukraine's
western partners have already sent or
promised to send military hardware worth
billions of dollars ukraine says it's
nowhere near sufficient and it's not
getting to the front lines fast enough
as nato defense ministers are scheduled
to meet in brussels on wednesday there
are many ukrainians increasingly asking
whether the west can sustain or even
build upon its level of military support
charles stratford al jazeera kiev